Welcome!
Oh my gosh, is that...
Bit Phantom of Ayami Family Collabo Cafe 2 fame?
Is that her?
The real deal?
Oh my gosh.
Can I...
No autographs.
Sorry.
Welcome back.
Happy Minto Day.
Happy Minto Day!
It's real.
Actually.
It's the real.
It's the realest.
Minto Day.
It's definitely today.
It's definitely right now.
I'm definitely not a day or two, depending on your time zone, late.
No,
I'm not singing Invisible by Duran Duran!
It's not even from Metal Gear!
Everyday is Minto Day.
Really?
March 10th is Minto Day and March 11th is Minky Day.
Minky...
Would there be a Minky Day?
I'm not sure actually.
They shouldn't be separated.
You know, I think I agree.
I think I agree.
They shouldn't be separated.
Anyway, for those everybody who does not know.
I just got back from a trip from Japan.
I was there for like a week and a half.
And...
I turned off the sounds.
I can still see them.
But I turned off the sounds.
And...
Boy, are her arms tired.
And hot dog.
She's hungover.
Oh yeah, totally.
I've never been so litty in my whole afterlife.
Except, yeah, I'm hungover from all that airplane wine.
Oh yeah.
Though, I don't drink much, but I went to...
I went to a bar.
I know, crazy.
And I got an oolong high.
And I didn't even feel a thing.
OMG, a bar.
I know!
Was it enjoyable?
Yeah, it tasted just like oolong tea.
So I was like, oh, okay.
I feel like I could understand why people get so drunk.
Mistolerance over here.
But you're only 17.
The person I possessed was not...
Also, I'm not 17.
I'm 19.
Which is probably...
Is probably...
Fine.
Spoiler, it was just tea.
I don't think they would rip me off.
Japan is 20.
I'm so close.
In spirit.
Short pour?
What's that mean?
Like a little bit?
They could've.
You've been 19 for long enough.
Hit that... Cue the Twilight meme.
How old are you?
19.
How long have you been 19?
A while.
OMG, thank you guys for all the superchats!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the hukasupo.
Suffering Mad Fomo.
The cafe!
I'm sorry for everybody who couldn't go.
But lots of people did go.
And I'm like...
I'm 19, you guys.
I'm 19.
It doesn't matter how many times I've been 19, okay?
Ghost time passes differently, okay?
Don't worry about it.
And let's not put random ages in the chat.
I think that's weird.
Let's not do that.
Let's only focus on 19.
Thank you!
Anyway.
It's Minto day.
And I just got back yesterday.
The collab cafe.
It's been absolutely so crazy.
Hold on, I put my glasses on.
Because I was like, I'm gonna...
I was like, I'm gonna do a little... I was gonna sing first.
And I felt like the glasses belonged to the song.
But then I changed my mind.
I'm still jet lagging.
Hangover glasses.
You guys, I'm so drunk.
Wait, no.
Hangover is not...
We're a hangover.
Are you...
It's not drunk.
Right?
Look how red her eyes are.
It's a headache.
It can be.
It's a...
Oh, it's dehydrated.
Oh.
I was expecting bloodshot eyes from watching Mufasa.
You guys, I watched Mufasa and I took notes.
Let me get my notes.
Hold on.
I took notes when I watched Mufasa so that I wouldn't forget what I had to talk about.
Note.
First of all though, my flight to Japan was so cursed.
It was extremely cursed because...
There was a lady for like...
Probably 90% of the plane.
She kept the window open.
And I'm like, hey lady.
The sun is not going to go down.
You're not going to catch that beautiful sunset.
You're not even going to catch a view.
There's nothing to see.
Please.
And then she was like reading her book with it open.
The entire time.
And I was like, there are overhead lights.
But, here's the kicker.
She...
Here, let me draw a picture for you guys.
Like literally.
I'm going to window capture.
Hold on.
Window capture.
Oh wait.
I don't remember how to stream anymore.
Window capture.
Paint.
I don't remember.
It feels like I've been gone for a whole month.
It's craziness.
Okay, so...
Alright.
So, here...
Here...
So my plane was like the type where it's like...
Two seats.
And then in the middle, there's like the row.
Right?
There's the row and then there's like three seats.
Or however many.
And another row.
I couldn't tell you which plane it was.
Usually I look up which plane it is.
Like if it's an Airbus or whatever.
So it was like this.
Sounds like a 747.
It might have been.
Is this lost?
So the seats were like this.
The seats were like this.
Anyway.
Ah, Minto...
Was here.
Right?
So I have an aisle seat.
But I'm also, you know...
Not next to the lady.
And this lady here...
Her window is wide open.
The sun is shining in to my entire row.
My entire row was getting flashbanged.
She also...
Hold on.
Before I get ahead of myself.
Is this Frogger?
Yes.
So I...
So lady goes up to the bathroom, right?
And I ask her, this lady here.
I was like, can you please...
Shut the window?
Please?
And she was just like, yeah, I don't know why she has it open.
First of all, usually the flight attendants say like...
Hey, even on my flight coming back they were like...
Hey, we need everybody to close the windows because it's gonna get bright.
I was just like, why didn't they ask her?
I don't understand.
And...
So...
She shuts it after I ask.
And then the girl comes back and it hasn't shut for a while.
And then she'll like do the thing where she like cracks it.
And then she does...
What?
What's wrong with my mouse?
Why is it not...
What the...
I'm dragging it.
Usually I see...
Oh, there's a drag.
Drag.
See?
What's wrong with my mouse?
Uh-oh.
My mouse is jet lagged too, yeah.
Oh no.
What's wrong with my mouse?
Okay, this is for another time.
Battery?
No, I just charged it.
I'll plug it in anyway.
Okay.
It's plugged up.
It's currently plugged up.
Uh-oh.
No!
First my car dies.
Then my mouse dies.
What's happening?
Your car died?
Oh yeah, that's another story.
Anyway, okay.
So she'll like crack it halfway and then like just...
Until it's bright, bright, bright.
Full brightness.
Everybody in my row.
But here's the kicker.
There was another guy on this side.
He also had his own window, right?
Because that's how planes work.
And he...
Hold on, let me move everything over.
He would look over at the girl sitting here.
He would look over at the girl sitting there and be like...
And I would watch him.
I would watch him do this.
He'd look over and be like...
Her window is open.
There must be something interesting outside.
Let me open my window too.
And so...
So...
They would...
They would constantly be opening and closing the windows.
And so I'm getting flashbanged from both sides.
And here's the kicker too.
Is that they're the only two people on the entire whole-ass plane that had their windows open.
Just my row!
Just my row.
And then...
I'm like okay.
I sleep.
I'll sleep.
You know what?
Fine.
I sleep.
Oh no wait, hold on.
Well yeah.
I would sleep and like she would have just a window open and I'm like...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna become the Joker here.
And I'm watching...
I'm watching a movie on my seat.
And then...
The...
The movie stops working.
My seat stops working.
And I was...
And they're like oh we have to reset the plane.
And they do.
And...
Everyone else...
Everyone else is happy watching their stuff.
She's reading.
She doesn't give a shit.
Everybody else is happy watching their plane movies.
Except my row.
Reset the plane?
Yeah!
They've never had to do that before?
They've never had to reset the system on the plane?
They had to do it three times.
It was a setup.
It was!
And so now...
I'm like okay I have no entertainment.
I wanted to watch a movie.
I was so close to finishing a movie.
And then...
I was...
Then...
When it rebooted the second time...
It was in like...
How do I say?
Like a...
You know when something reboots and it's not in full capacity working?
It's like a safety mode kind of deal?
It had like a limited selection of movies.
So I was like okay I'll pick one of these.
And then they were like we're gonna...
We're gonna reset again.
And then it just crashed completely.
And so I couldn't watch anything.
So I couldn't finish both movies.
And I couldn't sleep because I'm getting flashbanged.
By the sun.
It was just...
On the way back it was so funny because...
Because I was waiting in line for security.
And there was this guy who was just like chatting up these two girls in front of me.
In security line.
And he kept being like...
He definitely did not know them.
He was just talking to them.
And he was like several people in front of them, you know?
I don't know.
I don't know why he started talking to them.
But he was just like...
He was like you guys just gotta raw dog the flight.
You guys just gotta raw dog it.
No entertainment.
No...
No books.
No nothing.
You just gotta raw dog it.
And then as soon as they got away from the guy...
Where he...
Because the line kind of looped around or whatever.
And they were like...
Together they were like...
Why did he say that?
Does he know what raw dog means?
I was having like a flashback moment.
I was like...
They were like...
Why would he say that to us?
Doesn't he know what raw dogging means?
Why would he say that?
And he just kept saying it really loudly.
He was like...
You gotta raw dog the flight.
You just gotta raw dog it.
So that was...
That was my flight experience on the way there.
How did I get on that topic?
I don't know.
Oh, Mufasa!
Thank you.
Yeah, I watched Mufasa.
Oh!
I know what I was gonna say.
The first movie I was watching was...
I don't remember what it was called.
But it was about this lady who like...
Is a language professor and she's talking to...
The aliens and trying to figure out their language and what they want.
And I was like kind of invested in it.
I was like, oh, this is so interesting.
Arrival!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No spoilers because I never got to finish the movie.
And so I left in February, right?
And when I came back, it was March, right?
So they had updated...
They had updated the movies...
In the system.
I guess which one was removed.
I
never even got to finish it.
I never got to finish it.
Usually on trips, I'll like...
If I don't get to finish a movie, I'll continue where I left off on the way back, but...
You had the whole flight there.
What are you talking about?
The system went down.
It's not my fault?
Watch along maybe.
I don't know.
I have like 30 minutes left of it.
Meet me in the toilets if y'all want to watch this stream.
No!
Read?
Oh, you read.
I thought you said just read.
I was like, a book I don't have?
But anyway, Mufasa.
So I was able to watch that.
I watched Mufasa.
I watched...
Moana 2.
I tried watching that Emilia Perez movie.
I fell asleep.
And then I tried watching Deadpool Wolverine.
So I didn't...
So I didn't watch either of those.
I think I like, fell asleep at the very beginning of Deadpool.
I woke up to the credits.
Like I literally...
I literally slept through the entire thing.
And I only wanted to watch Emilia Perez because I heard of how bad it was.
And the music the very beginning...
The music was just so bad at the beginning.
I was...
Actually, no.
I didn't fall asleep during Emilia Perez.
I turned it off because...
Because it was so bad.
I was like, I can't listen to this.
I don't...
It's so terrible.
But, yeah.
Hate watching.
I wouldn't say hate watching.
I just want to know...
You know?
I just want to know what's it all about.
The only thing I know from that movie is the...
The part where he's just like...
Blah, blah, Plastias.
Blah, blah, blah, Plastias.
But you know what's also stupid is Mufasa.
Which...
Oh my gosh guys, this is a karaoke and I'm not just singing at all.
Okay, let's sing Mufasa.
Let's sing Mufasa's song and then I'll talk about Mufasa.
Wait, how do I look up Mufasa?
That movie was so bad.
Oh, this song sucks.
It's Mads Mikkelsen?
No.
What?
Mufasa movie.
Mads Mikkelsen.
No.
He sings the worst song.
Not Mads Mikkelsen.
No.
Are you kidding me?
There's a song in the movie that's worse than the brother song.
You guys, you wouldn't believe me.
But it's worse than the brother song.
I didn't know that was him.
He's actually a good singer.
The song is so bad.
It's so terrible.
Did he play Scar?
No, he played the villain in the movie.
Which is a guy named...
Hold on, I just googled it.
Akiros.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Let's sing a song.
Let's sing...
You know what, I don't know how this song goes, but I know that...
I'll sing...
This is the one he sings.
It's so bad.
This is my warm-up song, okay guys?
I think I remember how...
Wait.
You say you're the king, but you lie around in the shade.
Out of shape, unafraid.
The moon.
I'm gonna put on the...
What's the sound with the background vocals on it?
Here, you can sing.
I'm gonna be the last thing you see.
Before you go, bye bye.
There you go.
Bye bye.
Climb every tree.
Across land and sea.
I'll make you go, bye bye.
Everything that I touch is...
I don't know how to...
That's another thing I hated about the movie.
They're always just like...
A circle of life.
Like I get it.
Good Lion King.
Stop stealing glances.
They don't like your chances.
And neither do I.
I run my pride.
You run and hide.
Cause I'm gonna be the last thing you see.
Before you go, bye bye.
Climb every tree.
Across land and sea.
There you go.
Bye bye.
Before you go, bye bye.
I'm the last of my line.
I must be strong.
Bye bye.
I'll make you go, bye bye.
So bad.
Please tell me the song is called Bye Bye.
Would you...
How much you wanna bet for that?
Bye bye.
I'll make you go, bye bye.
It's so bad.
Also, I can't tell the lions apart.
It's too difficult.
It's too hard to know.
Never sing a song from Mufasa again?
Wait, what?
A broadcast?
Does it know I'm streaming?
I could sing it in Dutch.
You want me to sing Bye Bye in Dutch?
Rosie, thank you so much for the Akusuba.
Sorry, I feel like I'm missing so many superchats.
The chat is going by very quickly today for my jet-lagged eyes.
Thank you so much.
And then sometimes they would use this horrible...
Makes you appreciate Be Prepared.
Be Prepared is an amazing song.
They use this horrible GoPro camera on the lions when they were running sometimes.
And it's just extremely, extremely jarring and ugly.
And I can't tell what the expressions of the lions are.
And they're constantly referencing the circle of life and he lives in you.
I'm reading my notes.
I'm just like, I get it.
This is the Lion King.
I get it.
Oh my god.
I looked it up.
The song is called Bye Bye.
Bye bye.
I'll make you go bye bye.
He says it like that.
And so the movie basically is...
It's Lion King, but...
It's Mufasa origin story.
But told by Rafiki to Simba's daughter.
But also Timon and Pumbaa are interrupting.
And they're like, not enough Timon and Pumbaa in this story.
Thank you!
This sounds so convoluted.
It was!
It is!
And...
So it's also Lion King 1.5.
Kind of, actually.
Kind of.
And it's just very strange.
Scar's solo song is far above the quality of the rest of the film.
Being a song that Lin Manuel is best at.
Personal character songs.
But it's marred by being included in the rest.
Yeah, Scar's solo isn't so bad.
And then there's also another song that like...
Mufasa and...
Female lead...
Sing to each other.
Sarabi.
And that one wasn't so bad either.
Female lead.
Speaking of Lin Manuel...
Miranda...
Moana too.
He didn't write any of the music for that.
But I didn't mind Moana too so much.
I think it had a lot of criticisms.
The music was okay.
It wasn't great.
But, oh!
Oh my gosh.
Mufasa.
I'm sorry.
Spoilers, I suppose.
But the reason Scar becomes evil...
Is because Mufasa takes his girl.
Or the girl that he wants to get with.
A lion he's known for...
Like two days.
I'm sorry, excuse me!
Scar's...
It's so lame!
It's actually the lamest thing...
I've ever seen.
It's so...
It's so horrible.
Because Scar is just a little...
Piss baby the entire time.
He almost watches his mom die...
And he doesn't do anything.
And then he almost watches...
Sarabi die...
And doesn't do anything.
And Mufasa saves both of them both times.
And then, when Mufasa...
After he saves Sarabi, he credits...
Scar so that she'll love him instead.
And still, he's unlovable.
He's unlovable!
He's the worst!
What happened to Scar?
The cool Scar from...
Let's sing Lion King.
Unlovable Scar sounds like a sitcom.
Actually,
do I know Be Prepared?
I don't know if I do.
I don't know.
Whatever, I'm warming up you guys.
I'm warming up.
I'm warming up first.
My brain is so not here.
Yeah, I'm not prepared at all.
Be prepared...
For scuff.
Isn't this my part?
Oh, I had to leave vocal on.
This doesn't sound like him at all.
Maybe there's a...
Who is this?
If aligned to my vision...
And brain...
I know that your powers of retention...
Are as wet as a warthog's backside...
But thick as you are...
Pay attention!
My words are a matter of pride...
It's clear from your vacant expressions...
The lights are not all on upstairs...
But we're talking kings and successions...
Even you can't be caught unawares...
So prepare for the chance of a lifetime...
Be prepared for sensational news...
A shining new era...
Is tiptoeing nearer...
Where we feature...
Just listen to teacher...
I know it sounds sordid...
But you'll be rewarded...
When at last I'm given my dues...
An injustice deliciously squared...
Be prepared!
Let me turn on the vocals for this.
No fool, we're gonna kill him.
Great idea!
Who needs a king?
Idiots!
There won't be a king!
I will be king!
Stick with me...
And you'll never go hungry again!
He sounds better now.
There's so many parts in this song.
Of course, quid pro quo...
You were expected...
To take certain duties on board...
The future is littered with prizes...
And though I'm the main actressee...
The point that I must emphasize is...
You won't get a sniff without me!
So prepare for the coup of a century...
Be prepared for the murkiest scowl...
Meticulous planning...
Tenacity spanning...
Decadent of denial...
Wait, I don't think I said that right.
Disputed, respected, saluted...
And seen for the wonder that I am...
Guess my teeth and ambitions are bare...
Be prepared!
Guess our teeth and ambitions are bare...
I
didn't expect so much talking in that song.
Okay, I think I'm warmed up enough.
Another thing that I did while I was in Japan was I went to Disney.
Of course.
But...
I literally, mentally, I'm still on the Beauty and the Beast ride.
I can't...
I can't stop myself.
I wake up and I'm like, wow, Beauty and the Beast ride.
And then I go about my day and I'm like, wow, Beauty and the Beast ride.
And then I go to sleep and I'm like, wow, Beauty and the Beast ride.
It's such a beautiful ride!
I love that ride so much.
The teapots, yes!
Wait, yes?
Yeah.
But you're not talking about the teacups, right?
You never leave the ride.
I'm haunting it.
With my mind.
So I'm gonna sing some Beauty and the Beast.
I hope that's okay.
Just a couple songs.
Marseillaise, mademoiselle.
It is with deepest pride and greatest pleasure that we welcome you tonight.
And now we invite you to relax.
Let us pull up a chair as the dining room proudly presents your dinner.
Be our guest.
Put our service to the test.
Tie your napkin round your neck, sherry, and we'll provide the rest.
Soup du jour, hot hors d'oeuvres, why we only live to serve.
Try the great stuff, it's delicious.
Don't believe me?
Ask the dishes.
They can sing, they can dance.
After all, miss, this is France.
And a dinner here is never second best.
Go on, unfold your menu, take a glance, and then you'll be our guest.
Oui, our guest, be our guest.
Livre à goût, chez Soufflé, pie and pudding on flambé.
We'll prepare and serve with flair a culinary cabaret.
You're alone and you're scared, but the banquet's all prepared.
No one's gloomy or complaining while the flatware's entertaining.
We tell jokes, I do tricks with my fellow candlesticks.
And it's all in perfect taste that you can bet.
Come on and lift your glass, you won your own free pass.
To be our guest, if you're stressed, it's fine dining we suggest.
Be our guest, be our guest, be our guest.
Life is so unnerving for a servant who's not serving.
He's not whole without a soul to wait upon.
Ah, those good old days when we were useful.
Suddenly those good old days are gone.
Ten years we've been rusting, needing so much more than dusting.
Needing exercise, a chance to use our skills.
Most days we just lie around ze castle.
Flabby, fat and lazy, you walked in and oops-a-daisy.
It's a guest, it's a guest, six alive, all be blessed.
Wine's been poured and thank the Lord I've had the napkins freshly pressed.
With dessert, chill one tea, and my dear that's fine with me.
While the cups do their soft shoo-in, I'll be bubbling, I'll be brewing.
I'll get warm, piping hot, heaven's sakes is that a sport?
Clean it up, we want the company impressed.
We've got a lot to do, is it one lump or two?
For you our guest, she's our guest.
Guest, be our guest, our command is your request.
It's been years since we've had anybody here, and we're obsessed!
With your meal, with your ease, yes indeed we aim to please.
While the candlelight's still glowing, let us help you, we'll keep going.
By course, one by one.
Until you shout, enough, I'm done.
Then we'll sing you off to sleep as you digest.
Tonight we'll pop your feet, but now let's eat to be our guest.
Be our guest.
Please be...
I can't go so high.
Guest!
Maybe I'm not warmed up as I thought.
I should have warmed up before stream.
Wait, hold on.
Let me do a different song.
This one.
This one's awesome on the ride.
I love this ride.
Wait, do I have to be the beast?
I think I have to be the beast.
I can be the beast.
There's something sweet and almost kind.
But he was mean and he was coarse and unrefined.
And now he's dear and so unsure.
I wonder why I didn't see it there before.
I'm going beast mode!
Beast mode!
Okay, okay.
She glanced this way.
I thought I saw her.
She didn't shudder at my paw.
But then she's never looked at me that way before.
A new and a bit alarming.
Who'd have ever thought that this could be?
I can't look at Jack.
You guys are making me laugh.
True, that he's no Prince Charming.
But there's something in him that I simply didn't see.
Well, who'd have thought?
Well, bless my soul.
Well, who indeed?
Who had known?
Guess it comes together on their own.
It's so peculiar.
We'll wait and see.
A few days more.
There may be something there that wasn't there before.
You know, perhaps there's something there that wasn't there before.
What is it?
There may be something there that wasn't there before.
I'll tell you when you owe the chip.
Sorry.
This is like the most scuffed karaoke ever you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I can't take anything seriously.
But actually, this reminded me too.
I see this on here.
Is that I was walking around the park in the Beauty and the Beast area.
And they had an instrumental of this version.
Or of this song.
Which is only from the movie, but it's like probably my favorite.
I think it became like one of my favorite...
Beauty and the Beast songs.
It's only from the live action movie.
And they had an instrumental playing in the park and I was so like...
I can't believe they're acknowledging this song.
So...
So I sing this one.
I don't think I need to change the pitch.
But because of this, because I heard it in the park, I was like OK.
I want to do a watch along of this movie now.
Maybe we'll do it later this week.
Yeah, the Emma Watson one.
But she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
It's more than I can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me.
Even as she runs away.
She will still torment me, call me, hurt me.
Move me, come what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower.
Waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in.
And be with me forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love.
I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach.
She's never out of sight.
Now I know she'll never leave me.
Even as she fades from view.
She will still inspire me, be a part of everything I do.
Wasting in my lonely tower.
Waiting by an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in.
And as the long, long nights begin.
I'll think of all that might have been.
Waiting here forevermore.
Forevermore.
Oh, I forgot about Celis.
I'm so sorry.
My voice is not very good today.
I think the dryness from the plane has killed me even more than I already am.
What did I say?
Let's not think about Mufasa.
I sang...
Be our guest.
23.
Oh, be prepared.
That was a warm up.
Warm up.
Be prepared.
And then I did something there.
This is not a Disney karaoke.
Sorry, I just have Disney on the brain right now.
I'm maybe a certified Disney adult.
I don't know.
Do you mind if I open the window?
Stop!
Kiss the girl.
Disney adult.
That was Evermore.
From the movie.
I'm going to stop thinking about you saying I go men oof Chan with your Beast voice.
I go men oof Chan.
Oh, there's my oomph right there.
That's oomph.
That's oomph right there.
Apparently the Beast's real name is Prince Adam.
Saw it on a toy once.
No, his name is the Beast.
Not to be confused with another Beast.
Mr. Notoriety.
The last name Beast.
Even after he turns human.
Nobody wants him to turn human though.
Nobody wants him to actually turn human.
Everybody says go back Beast, go back!
Wait, the actor?
What actor is in Severance?
I think Belle still called him Beast after he turned back.
I sure hope so.
Yeah.
Belle asked him to grow a beard?
She was totally into it.
I just call him Mr. He's like, don't call me Mr. Beast.
That's my dad.
That's my father.
Thank you guys for all the... Ally, thank you so much for membership and thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you guys.
Hayden, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Nerdy Laundry, thank you for the five gifted.
Sorry, I'm so bad at reading everything today and saying thank you today.
My brain is literally moving at one megapit... pit?
Not my pits.
Megapits.
Megabit.
One bit.
A single...
It's moving very slowly.
Invisible Booze, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Disney songs are reminding me of Doki and Mint's adventures in Minecraft.
Oh, it was so fun.
Tony, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you!
Megapits.
It's like, what was that?
The Megamilk shirt?
Does anybody still remember that?
Does anyone still care about the Megamilk shirt?
Is that a dead meme now?
Probably.
I do.
I remember.
Oh my gosh, my throat is so bad today.
Someone asked for Hercules earlier.
Hercules.
I don't remember so many Hercules.
This isn't...
This isn't a... Sorry, people are messaging me.
This isn't a Disney karaoke.
Would say I'm in love.
Okay.
Have no... anything for today.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
I didn't realize it started.
Okay, one more redo!
If there's a prize for rotten judgment, I guess I've already won that.
No man is worth the aggravation.
That's ancient history, been there, done that.
Who'd you think you're kidding?
He's the earth and heaven to you.
Try to keep it hidden.
Oh no!
No chance, no way, I won't say it, no, no.
It's too cliché, I won't say I'm in love.
I thought my heart had learned its lesson.
It feels so good when you start out.
My head is screaming, get a grip, ghost!
Unless you're dying to cry your heart out.
Oh no!
Oh,
no chance, no way, I won't say it, no, no.
Give in, check the grid, you're in love.
This scene won't play, I won't say I'm in love.
I think I got that note wrong.
I won't say it, get off my case, I won't say it.
Girl, don't be proud, it's OK, you're in love.
At least I'm loud, I won't say I'm in love.
It can't make me!
It can't make me say it.
Oh, where did the setlist go?
Sorry, I'm so messed up today.
I'm so messed up today.
I won't say I'm in love.
What did I just move?
Just kidding.
Oh my gosh, I'm so messed up today.
Today?
Yes, today.
Usually, I'm OK, usually.
Ohayo!
Ohayo, ohayo.
Yeah, Meg is so tsundere.
Thank you for tsundere love song.
You're welcome.
Yeah, you're welcome.
There was...oh, what else do I want to sing?
Oh, I remember.
Oh, the reason I have my glasses on.
Hold on.
The reason I have my glasses...oh.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I wanted to sing a cool...I wanted to sing this because...
I heard it the other day and I was just like...
I was like...
Hey, this should be when I leave, OK?
This is how I feel.
Inside and out and love's strange.
So real in the dark.
So lovely come the tender things that we were working on.
Slow change may pull us apart.
When the light gets into your heart, baby.
Don't you forget about me.
Don't, don't, don't you forget about me.
Can you stand above me?
Rain keeps falling, rain keeps falling down and down.
Reminds me, call my name or walk on by.
Rain keeps falling, rain keeps falling.
It's my feeling going in the end.
I want defenses, vanity and security.
Oh, don't you forget about me.
I'll be alone dancing.
You know it, baby.
Going
back together at heart.
Forget about me.
My name.
Or will you walk away?
If you see me on the streets, go Mickey!
Will you walk on by?
Come on, call my name, will you?
Mickey!
I say la, la, la, la, la.
Yeah, OK.
Now you guys won't forget about me, OK?
Don't you forget about me.
This song is way deeper than I thought it would be.
La, la, la, who?
Don't say who!
It's Mickey!
It's Mito!
It's me!
Don't say the who, that's a band!
No!
No, don't say hey, it's for horses!
OK, I'm over it.
Sorry, I got really big all of a sudden.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift cards!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Jump scare.
I wonder if they have...oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I was so stressed about the collab cafe, you guys.
I can't tell you how much I was like...
Oh gosh, will anybody go to it?
Because...OK, let me explain my reasoning.
Because people are like...
Mint is going to say...
I saw, I saw, I saw.
People being like, Mint is going to be like, I can't believe so many people went to the maid cafe.
Underestimating, blah, blah, blah, whatever, whatever.
But, but...
I thought that, you know, OK, hear me out.
People, people, you know...
It's Japan and I don't have so many fans in Japan.
And also, also, I...
I was like thinking, oh, you know, some people might not go because they have other plans.
Like, you know, yeah, fest, like holo fest or, or, or, or...
Expo or whatever.
And, well, I mean, I did pick around that time because I figured more people would be in Japan.
But I also was just like, oh, you know, hololive fans are probably not a fan of maid-o-minto.
So, um...
So, I...
Was like, I, I, and I was so stressed out.
I actually, like the first couple of days, I got this like...
Hopefully you can't see it.
I got this horrible like rash, like stress rash on my, on my neck.
Luckily it was so cold I just always wore, I just always wore, uh, uh, turtlenecks.
But...
But I was like...
I was like, oh my god, it hurts so bad.
It's so bad.
I was like, only, I just touched my neck and I was like, oh, I still feel it.
It's like, it's getting a bit better.
But I was, I was truly stressing, okay?
I was really stressing out about it.
Okay, so...
Yeah.
What do you mean hickey?
No, no, it was not.
What are you talking about?
Stop, stop making fun of my pain.
Fun of my pain.
The pain, the pain.
It was like, it was like across my entire neck.
Like, it was my entire, actually it was my entire neck.
Like someone had choked me out.
But it was like itchy and hurt.
And I was like, this is so embarrassing, I can't go outside.
I can only wear turtlenecks.
So...
So, I, you know, for anybody who was just like...
Why didn't she think anybody would go?
I honestly had no idea.
Okay, okay.
Gosh, like a phantom pain.
You guys, I don't think you know what hickeys are.
I don't think you guys know what that is.
Isn't it basically a bruise?
A hickey.
Isn't it?
Yes.
Yeah, we do.
Then why if I say I got a rash, you think it's a hickey?
Why do you think that?
Because it's on your neck.
Okay, I understand.
Sometimes if I'm with Mitara and she meets someone...
She'll be like, I see that hickey on your neck.
Not talking to me, talking to the other person.
And I'm like...
First of all, if it is a hickey, why are you pointing it out?
But second of all, why would you just say that to somebody?
Why would you just call them out like that?
Why would you say that?
Because she is Mitara.
Classic Mitara.
True.
That reflects the streamer.
Can you teach me what a hickey is?
I'm a hands-on learner.
Shut up.
My thoughts are built different.
I truly...
Extroverts are so scary.
They say anything.
And she'll just be like...
Go to the person and be like, I see that hickey on your neck.
Mitara, decorum, please.
And I don't even notice it either.
I'm like, how would you know that it's a hickey and not just like...
I don't know, something else.
How would you even know?
I think that's just Mitara.
Potentially.
Wait, is this live?
Yeah, I'm live.
Actually no, I'm dead.
I'm not live at all.
I've been dead my whole afterlife.
I've been dead my whole afterlife you guys.
Hold on.
I was gonna...
There is another song I wanted to sing, but I need to...
I need to up the pitch.
Up to see if I have it.
Let's see, maybe here.
Grandma.
No.
Oh no, do they not have a pitch version?
Hold on, let me...
Let me see.
Basically...
Oh my gosh you guys, I was in Akihabara when it snowed both times.
I was in Akihabara when it snowed both times and I was like...
But the second time I was in Akihabara, it was...
It was...
Sorry.
I'm so slow today.
Not it was, I was...
I was at a maid cafe.
And I could see the snow from the window.
And I was like...
And the maids were like, oh my gosh, should we...
Should we sing Snow Halation?
Anybody wanna sing Snow Halation?
Let's go!
Except, one guy that was at the cafe, he was just like, no, no Snow Halation.
I'm gonna sing, I'm gonna have you guys sing this song instead.
And it's like, so depressing.
I was like, why would you...
Why would you ask them to sing this song instead?
Because it's so depressing.
It's literally from a drama called One Liter of Tears.
And so, it's like, just a sad song.
But I was like, oh my gosh, I haven't heard this song in so long, so I'm gonna sing it.
I'm gonna sing it.
Yeah, but we did not get... Maybe I should have requested Snow Halation.
I'm gonna get rid of my glasses.
This is not a freak phantom moment.
Have you guys watched that movie though, One Liter of Tears?
It was a movie that...
Was it a movie or a series?
Actually, now I can't remember, but I really liked it.
It's about this girl who has this rare degenerative brain disorder.
When I first watched it, I was like, oh my gosh, I wanna become a nurse.
And then, I failed chemistry.
No, I didn't fail.
I barely passed chemistry.
And I also was like, I'm afraid of needle.
So I said...
I don't think I should become a nurse.
But the sentiment is still there.
Anyway, I'm gonna sing this song.
It's called Konayuki by Remi Yoroman.
And actually, they have another song called Sangatsu Kokonoka.
Which I was like, oh my gosh, I can sing that song because I'll be streaming on Sangatsu Kokonoka.
And then I was like, no, I'm not.
It's...
I'll sing it anyway.
I was like...
That's the 9th.
It's not even close.
It is close enough though, right?
It is Sangatsu, yeah.
It's not March 9th at all.
But it's close enough, maybe.
Okay, hold on, let me take a sippy.
I found this pitched up version, but...
I don't know how it is.
Maybe it's okay.
Oh, wait.
That's the pitch.
I
read the kanji.
Okay, I think that's it.
Okay, sorry, redo.
Konayuki lyrics.
I can't read the...
There's no furigana, why?
I can't read.
There's no furigana.
One more time!
Kanji is hard.
It's hard, right?
I don't think the pitch is right.
Maybe I should just check the original, but it's really low.
I don't know.
This
is so...
Harsh.
You know?
I can't read the kanji.
I
can't read.
I can't read.
Cursed.
So cursed.
Why would they put it plus 5?
Why would they put it plus 5 instead of like...
I always do like plus 2.
It's too high!
Wait, I just saw a plus 3 version.
Oh my god.
Wait, let me hear what this one sounds like.
This one's probably...
It already sounds better.
Why plus 5?
I give up.
I give up!
Let's do the next one.
I think maybe this one I can do without a pitch.
We'll see.
Hold on.
Stop spamming!
Everyone in the moon.
Anyway, redo!
I don't think this is from One Litre of Tears.
Same album though, as the other song.
So high!
I give up.
I don't remember that part.
March 9th.
How do I put this?
Let me just write it in Japanese.
There we go.
Heaven's divide.
I can try it.
I should've really come in with a setlist.
You guys, I'm so sorry.
I was like, I can chill, I can sing, I can yap about my trip.
Whatever, whatever.
All good.
No stress.
So sorry if it's a little...
You know?
It's a little all over.
Oh my gosh, if I search Heaven's Divide karaoke, I see...
I see a clip channel with my...
Oh my gosh, I see myself.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I think it's this one.
Thank you!
I have something for you guys later.
I do.
I have something for you later.
Of course, when the stars align.
I will reach out to you.
And leave this all behind.
With Heaven's Divide.
I think I'll start Peace Walker this week.
We can all play.
I want to play Peace Walker so bad.
Which console I haven't decided yet.
Probably Xbox.
Since I did PlayStation last time.
When Heaven's Divide, I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fear.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When Heaven's Divide, time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When Heaven's Divide.
Also yes, I did see the Death Stranding 2 trailer.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I will dive into the fire, spilling the blood of my desire.
The very last time my name scorched into the sky.
When Heaven's Divide, I will see the choices within my hands.
How can we ever protect and fight with our tiny souls?
Let me shine like the sun through the doubts and fears.
Do you feel the storm approach as the end draws near?
When Heaven's Divide, time will come to softly lay me down.
Then I can see a face that I long to see.
And for you, only you, I would give anything.
Leaving a trace for love to find a way.
When Heaven's Divide.
Leaving a trace for love.
Yay!
Heaven's Divide.
Nice.
Metal Gear.
Yay, yay, yay.
Thanks Donnerburg.
Metal Gear.
Nice.
Nice, Metal Gear.
What's another spring song?
What's another springy song?
Spring spring time.
Springy spring can be English or Japanese.
Japanese.
Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai.
Do I even have that on here?
I think I would have to load up my...what's it called?
Tsuyoi.
That's a Denpo Gumi song.
Kimochi.
I think you're talking about the Denpo Gumi song, no?
Tsuyoi ai.
What is it?
Wait, is it a cover?
Actually, I have no idea.
Wait, hold on.
I only know the Denpo version.
Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai.
I never knew it was a cover!
I'm an idiot.
I think I can sing this version.
Probably.
Because I know the Denpo Gumi version.
Let's do it.
Let's try it.
Today is whatever whatever.
Who wants to dance?
Stand up!
It's a little off the pitch.
Hara ato yuma no shiru hirou Afureru hikari koe midori Atarashii kamisamatachi ga Patto hanayagu Mahou o kakeru Machi wa fukaku bokura wo utau It's so low, though!
Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai Kokoro wo gyutto tsunagu Ikutsu no kanashimi mo Okorasu sasageau Ima kono kimochi Really?
Right?
Shiru koneko no you ni Boku wa kiseki wo matteita yoru Okurasu
wo sagashite ita kedo Nante tanjun de bakana ore Machi wa fukaku bokura wo inaku
Kanashimi mo okorasu sasageau
Oh my god, it's the overlapping part.
Yorokobi no naka e Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai Nante!
Dancing in the street, baby!
Kanzashitai no wa dare?
Osukushita hora
Utsukushii sora Hibikiau sora Daremo mita koto no nai hibi mo Ryukui
kimochi Tsuyoi
kanashimi mo Okorasu
sasageau I'm so much more used to the Denpagumi version.
But the original is also so funky.
It's fun.
It's also a pitch higher for the Denpagumi one.
Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai And then it gets faster.
So it's really fun.
I wonder if there's any Denpagumi.
Denpagumi Denpagumi ink!
Semai suteji kara Sekai wo mezase Tsutai yo Miri miri no denpa Doko made mo yukeru It doesn't seem like it.
It's ok.
I'll just cry about it.
Yeah, I love the speed up.
It's so fun.
I definitely recommend the Denpagumi version of that song.
Tsuyoi kimochi tsuyoi ai
They're both different kinds.
Yeah, they're both different...
Vibes, right?
Are you using Kiara-fun tonight?
I am!
Why?
Is there Denpagumi on there?
Nope.
Wait, maybe with an N.
Instead of an M.
Did you even make it through?
I could make it through WWD.
What are you talking about?
Wait, let me see.
WWD instrumental.
If they have it, I'll sing it.
Denpagumi WWD.
Oh, do you mean by crying?
Oh, without crying?
Let's see.
For those who don't know, Denpagumi is my favorite idol group.
In January, I went and saw them disband.
And it was so beautiful and sad.
But the song WWD is about basically how they met and how they were all bullied.
And they were all like nerds who didn't really have a real direction in their life.
And then they all met each other.
They all joined Denpagumi and were like, we're gonna go from this small, small stage and we're gonna reach a worldwide audience.
Everybody will know the name Denpagumi.
And it's so beautiful.
Thinking about it, I might cry already.
Let's try singing it.
Oh gosh, wait, there's other languages here.
Hello, we are Denp- wait, oh, wait, hold on, wait, hold on.
I was reading the translation.
That's so funny.
Hold on, one more time.
Instead of the bonjour, nous sommes Denpagumi Inc.
Bonjour, nous sommes Denpagumi Inc.
Group of the idol of Japanese.
I can't read and I'm being poor.
Akihabara to all over the world.
Season's Greeting.
Let's go!
I have a big dream.
Even if I lose, it's fine, it's fine.
What is it?
Come on, come on.
Denpagumi Inc.
Now, it's a small, small, small, small stage.
We can go as far as we want.
There's nothing to throw away.
It's a start from minus.
Today, too, I'm going to go, go, go, go, go,
go.
We're going to win with our style.
There's no place to live.
Now, for the sake of my dream, I'm going to let it go.
Denpagumi Inc.
Let me tell you how to use Uryaoi.
Please shout it twice after our singing.
Five!
Uryaoi!
Worldwide!
Japanese is hard, too.
Uryaoi!
Heart!
Denpagumi Inc.
Even if I lose, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I feel like I've been born.
I'm finally starting to understand myself.
I don't go to school anymore.
I only use the internet.
I'm not lonely online.
Me too.
I don't go out of my room at all.
I didn't want to go out of my room.
I loved everything online.
I had a girlfriend who was an internet celebrity.
We were enemies.
I've been a cosplayer since I was a kid.
I admired the cute and sparkling world.
I've always seen it.
I was small and shiny.
And I couldn't do anything.
Time has passed and I'm a high school student.
Time has passed and I'm a maid.
For some reason, the two of us are now...
Oh, I was fast.
We are together.
I was in Akihabara after I killed my ex-wife.
A maid cafe where I work.
A girl.
She was so cute.
She looked lonely.
I was hurt.
But she gave me meaning.
I want to be a little more powerful.
I thought so.
But we broke up.
Lily.
Lisa.
Nemu.
Eri.
Oga.
Riki.
The three of us are now...
One.
I've been through a lot.
I had a dream.
I do it every day.
Our name is...
Denpagumi.
Let's go!
From a small stage.
Aim for the world.
I want to tell you.
And then start.
What is it like?
I can't read the words.
That part is so hard.
It's like...
Wait, wait, wait.
It's just the days of the week.
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys know?
Lactobacillus KCI.
I love Yakult.
I was telling my friends the other day about the Lactobacillus KCI.
Wait, let me find it.
I think I still have it in my history.
No, I don't have it.
Wait.
Lactobacillus KCI.
Lactobacillus...
Yakult.
Hold on.
Lactobacillus KCI.
Lactobacillus...
No.
Lactobacillus KCI.
Yakult.
Yeah.
I can't say it without reading it.
I love Prairie Puppets.
Lactobacillus KCI bacillus.
No.
Lactobacillus KCI.
I keep adding a bacillus.
Like it's a dinosaur.
Lactobacillus.
No, it's not Lactobacillus.
It's Lactobacillus KCI bacillus.
Lactobacillus KCI bacillus.
Lactosaurus.
Happy birthday!
How do I say your name?
Next joke.
It's not a joke.
It's real.
Is my existence a joke to you?
Not that I'm the lactobacillus.
Let's go back to an English song.
Let's go back to English.
Oh wait, I did WWD.
Kind of.
Actually, that one was kind of painful to do.
Not going to lie.
My throat is not so great today.
I think I will take a break.
I have to record a bunch of stuff.
So I'm going to have to...
I'm going to have to preserve my voice for a while.
What's an English song?
What's a spring song?
Spring song.
Spring.
It's spring time.
What are you recording?
That's for me to know and for you to never find out.
No, I'm not singing Snow Halation because someone annoyed me earlier about it.
Someone was spamming in chat earlier about Snow Halation.
I said, no.
I won't sing it now.
It is.
I just said I wanted to go back to English songs.
But actually, this might be on here.
It is.
I'll have some guy sing the voice.
The name.
Scared me.
Sorry, hold on.
What's the harmony there?
Sorry.
Sorry for the break.
Wait, what was it?
Wait, I don't remember.
Okay, I'll try it.
Redo!
Sorry.
Sorry, I ran out of breath at the last bit.
Victor-san, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
This song is confusing because it doesn't tell you when it's the girl part and when it's the boy part.
It doesn't tell you.
This song is so good though, right?
There's another song.
It's not...
Okay, well this is...
This is...
We're going through the seasons now at this point.
We'll do this one.
That didn't count me in!
Okay.
Itsumo dori no aru hi no koto Kimi wa totsuzen tachiagari ita Kon'ya hoshi wo mi ni yukou
Nante mina shite itte waratta Akari mo nai michi wo Baka mitai ni hashaide aruita Kakaekonda kodoku ya fuan ni
Oshitsubusarenai you ni Bakugan na sekai kara miageta Yozora wa hoshi ga furu you de When did I start chasing you?
Please don't be surprised.
Listen to my feelings.
Areca de neve, areca il vega.
You are a summer triangle pointing at me.
I remember and look at the sky.
I finally found you, Orihime.
But where are you, Hikoboshi-sama?
Now I'm all alone.
You are next to me, a fun person.
I can't say anything.
Actually, I've known you for a long time.
Even if I find you, I can't reach you.
No, don't cry.
That's what I said.
I'm a strong coward.
I pretended not to be interested.
But...
The pain in my chest is getting worse.
Ah, I see.
So this is what it feels like to fall in love.
There's a mix here and I never remember it.
Every time.
I'll learn it one day.
It's a song for... a remix for this song.
Together?
Okay!
Yeah, we should.
Go down to the stars.
I hear your voice.
The truth is cruel.
I didn't say it.
I couldn't say it.
I can't go back.
That summer day.
Sparkling stars.
I can still remember it now.
A smiling face.
An angry face.
I loved you.
It's strange, isn't it?
I knew it.
You don't know.
My secret.
Beyond the night.
A distant memory.
You pointed at me.
With an innocent voice.
I found it though.
I found the mix.
She looks eepy.
I was looking down on my phone trying to find it.
Hold on, I can find it.
A story you don't know.
If you heard that, that was my tummy.
Sorry.
Hold on, I found it.
I found it.
To the star of hope.
What kanji is that?
I don't know.
I copy and paste.
Copy and paste.
To the star of hope.
It's a good kojou, I think.
You are wrong.
You are strong.
And then you say that Oshii name.
Really.
I fell in love with you.
I will never let go of your hand.
I want to wish for this moment.
I have been looking at you.
I can't say it with courage.
But in my heart...
What is that?
Oku?
But in my heart...
This feeling that pierces me.
After all...
Did you say mint?
I love mint.
I love it.
That's the mix.
To the star of hope.
I fell in love with you.
I will never let go of your hand.
I want to wish for this moment.
I have been looking at you.
I can't say it with courage.
It's basically saying like...
I will muster the courage.
Or maybe not.
I love you.
Let's try it.
Let's see if we can do it.
Hold on.
Even if I find you.
I can't reach you.
It's a dream.
Don't cry.
That's what I said.
Wait.
It's after this part.
To the star of hope.
I fell in love with you.
I will never let go of your hand.
I want to wish for this moment.
I have been looking at you.
I can't say it with courage.
It's basically saying like...
I will muster the courage.
Wait.
I messed up.
I got the wrong part.
I got the...
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
Let me split it apart like this.
For me to easily remember.
Hold on.
I have been looking at you.
I want to wish for this moment.
I will never let go of your hand.
Wait.
I want to wish for this moment.
I have been looking at you.
And then this part is...
I can't say it with courage.
Oh wait.
No.
I can't say it.
But...
This feeling that pierces my heart.
I love you, Mint.
I love you.
One more time.
Let's try it again.
See you.
I swear to the stars.
I will muster the courage.
I will never let go of your hand.
I want to wish for this moment.
I have been looking at you.
I can't say it with courage.
But this feeling that pierces my heart.
I love you, Mint.
I love you.
Do you remember?
Are you ok?
Again.
Do you know it now?
There we go.
Now we know it.
We learned it together.
I don't remember.
Practice more.
Everyone practice properly.
I don't remember at all.
Learn it.
Practice it.
This one is kind of...
It's hard to learn sometimes the calls that are for song specific stuff, you know?
It's ok.
Denpogumi has a couple and they are very long.
They are very very long.
It's hard to remember.
Oh my gosh.
Did you guys see the picture?
Hold on, let me grab it.
The picture I posted on Twitter.
This one.
I took it.
I went on a night walk.
And even though it was so cold.
It was so cold.
I saw this.
Like this.
See it?
The three stars that make a triangle.
That's the moon by the way.
It's not the sun.
It's the moon.
And the three stars.
I was like oh my gosh.
It's spring but I saw the stars and I was like...
And then when I was walking around I had that song stuck in my head.
So I kind of wanted to sing Kimi no Shiranai Monogatari because it was stuck in my head the other night.
Because I was walking around.
Did you point and say the names?
With your phone?
Yeah, that was with my phone.
Maybe.
I don't know actually.
There is another song I want to sing.
This song I feel is very...
Let me see if...
This song feels like a...
I don't think I've ever sung this song before.
Oh, I forgot to do.
It feels like a fall song to me so I want to sing it.
This will probably 100% get claimed.
But that's okay.
If it gets claimed to where it gets blocked in countries I'll just censor it.
But this song is all about seasons.
It was!
It was so pretty.
And then next to the Tokyo Tower.
It was so nice.
Why isn't the lyrics loading?
This sucks.
Oh, I got it.
This is actually... I don't think I've ever sung this song before.
It's by an idol group called Keyakizaka46.
Which, they're not around anymore.
They got like changed into... Are they now Sakurazaka I think?
Maybe?
I think?
What did they change into?
I can't remember.
Anyway.
Sorry, I'm spacing out.
Let me make sure this instrumental is good.
Let me make sure.
Okay, it's like an immediate start so I have to be on my toes.
How do you guys think of the new... I changed my...
Why am I blinking like a frog?
I changed my karaoke set... or not karaoke, sorry.
Oh my gosh, I think I'm starting to crash out.
That's not the mean... wait, that's not how that works.
I'm starting to crash a little bit.
I changed my reverb settings a little bit.
I don't know how it sounds though.
If it sounds okay.
Minky tired.
I'm so eepy.
I'm so eepy!
And I'm getting hungry.
Crash bandicoot.
It sounds good?
Okay, cool.
I'm so eepy.
I'm
so eepy.
Yeah.
That was Futari Saison.
Futari Saison.
Saison.
Thank you!
I feel like those kinds of songs are much better sung as a group.
So I recommend listening to the original.
And oh my gosh, their uniforms in the music video are so pretty.
Hi, I'm glad you're back even though I'm missing the radio.
Thank you!
Ayumi Hamasaki's Depend On You.
I don't think I know it.
I don't think I know it, I'm sorry.
Never misses on the uniforms.
They were so good!
Unwritten.
I can do unwritten.
But every time I sing that song, people are like, it's the...
Laundry detergent?
Or whatever.
Is that a spring song?
Unwritten?
Wasn't this used in an ad for...
For laundry or something?
Unwritten.
Can't read my mind.
Okay, redo because the lead vocals were on.
Unwritten.
Can't read my mind.
I'm just beginning.
The pen's in my hand.
Ending unplanned.
Staring at the blank page before you.
Open up the dirty window.
Let the sun illuminate the words that you could not find.
Reaching for something in the distance.
So close you can almost taste it.
Release your inhibitions.
Feel the rain on your skin.
No one else can feel it for you.
Only you can let it in.
Why does she say ah the entire song?
She doesn't stop!
When your book begins, the rest is still unwritten.
Even there!
I break
tradition.
Sometimes my tries are outside the lines.
We've been conditioned to not make mistakes.
But I can't live that way.
Oh no.
Out of the blank page before you.
Out of the dirty window.
Let the sun illuminate the words that you could not find.
Out for something in the distance.
Oh so close you can almost taste it.
Release your inhibitions.
Feel the rain on your...
May I ask?
No one else, no one else can speak the words on your lips.
Drench yourself in words unspoken.
With arms wide open.
Today is where your book begins.
The rain on your skin.
No one else can feel it for you.
Only you can let it in.
No one else, no one else can speak the words on your...
Drench yourself.
Release your inhibitions.
Feel the rain on your skin.
No one else can feel it for you.
Only you can let it in.
No one else, no one else can speak the words on your...
Drench yourself in words unspoken.
Live your life with arms wide open.
Today is where your book begins.
Feel the rain on your skin.
No one else can feel it for you.
Only you can let it in.
No one else, no one else can speak the words on your...
Drench yourself in words unspoken.
I can't anymore.
You guys have to understand.
Hold on, let me show you what I'm seeing.
Let me show you what I'm seeing.
Because it shows up in the background of the video, right?
Like, hold on, carophone.
So while I'm singing it, I just see the little...
The little...
Just popping up over and over and over again.
Hold on, I'll show you.
I'll show you, I'll show you.
Oh, I don't want you to see.
Hold on.
I don't know what that QR code goes to.
I don't want you to put it in songs.
I don't know if it does that.
That would be scary.
Okay, hold on.
Do you see it?
I just see it in the background over and over again.
And then even in the chorus.
I can't stop seeing it.
I can't stop seeing it, you guys.
Sorry, I couldn't take the song seriously.
Unwritten.
Written.
Is it rare for songs to include... Is that rare for songs to include in a karaoke?
I think to that extent, maybe.
Unwritten.
You sound like Yoshi Yoshi.
Oh my gosh, I love that song.
Kaerimichi wa.
It's a little fast for me though.
Maybe next time.
Let me see.
I wonder if they have it on here.
No.
I love that song though.
Kaerimichi wa.
Orange from ToraDora!
Doing a lot of JP songs today.
That's okay though.
ToraDora.
I love this song.
The new Gundam movie has some amazing songs.
Worth a watch if you have a chance.
Oh, yes!
Wasn't it in theaters?
In North America recently?
No?
Am I... Yes?
Right?
Oh my gosh.
I love you.
No, it's not like that.
Mandarin orange.
I ran away.
Then, the light won't shine on me.
won't shine on me.
Even though it's a miracle.
Encounters, love, seeds, and buds are still blue.
I don't want to know my future.
I ate everything.
It's sour.
I love you, but I'll cry.
I love you, so I'll cry.
Because I can't
leave you like me.
I love you.
It's sour.
Yay!
That was orange.
I should give you guys the gift now.
Before I forget.
Because I just saw it.
I have to remember to give it to you guys.
It was a Mito day.
Actually, I had two things that I wanted to give you guys.
But the other thing won't be done until later.
So, please accept this small little gift from me.
It's a Mito original outfit.
Wallpaper!
Made by my mama.
Ayami mama!
Yeah!
So, I'll upload this afterwards.
In the community tab.
So, I just, you know, thank you guys.
I thought it would be cute.
There's a few changes.
I can see.
It's the old outfit, but with a few changes.
Yeah.
Of course, with my new hair and everything.
But, yay!
It may or may not be an opai window.
Where the opai at?
And then she added some cuffs to my wrists, which I think are pretty cute.
And a choker.
I hardly even know her.
Yeah!
So, I'll upload this after stream.
For you guys to use.
For your...
If you want to.
I think it's pretty cute.
So, you know.
Opai window.
It's...
Oh, I...
Yeah.
So, yes.
Thank you Ayami Mama for creating that.
For...
For Minto Day.
She's pointing at me.
It could be you.
Another song I want to sing because I listen to this song.
Actually, I have a couple songs.
This one, I never do it justice, but I like singing it anyway.
Because I like this song a whole lot.
So, I'm gonna sing it and I heard it at Holofest.
Well, I wasn't at the fest.
I heard it at Expo, but they were playing it.
Okay.
Oh!
Star Wars!
Star Wars Star Wars
Star Wars Star Wars I won't tell you, still love, still love, in the middle of the universe Tonight's music will surely, surely never stop That's right, what I've always wanted to become Isn't a waiting Cinderella I'm a prince going to the deep sea Because I'm a star That's
right, I was a star
Stella, Stella
Stella...
I'll do 20 songs today.
Here I go flying!
Never do it justice.
I always feel like I mess it up in the middle.
And that my voice is not powerful enough for the chorus.
That's the one I saw live, like I was at the creator stage.
And I got so...
I don't remember the verses.
Because I've only heard the... what's it called?
The chorus so much because of like shorts and everything.
So I don't remember how the verses go.
I'll sing Bibbidi another time.
There's another song I want to sing.
This one's a little more low key.
Wait, hold on.
One second, one second.
Hold on, hold on.
Next song!
Next song.
The whole is just karaoke Bibbidi on the karaoke.
That's so funny.
Oh yeah, I saw that they were doing like a Big Off collab, right?
This song is dedicated to my tiny snake.
My little guy.
Just like me They long to be close to you Why do stars fall down from the sky Every time you walk by Just like me They long to be close to you On the day that you were born, the angels got together And decided to create a dream come true So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair And golden starlight in your eyes of blue That is why all the girls in town Follow you all around Just like me,
they long to be close to you
On the day that you were born, the angels got together And decided to create a dream come true So they sprinkled moon dust in your hair And golden starlight in your eyes of blue That is why all the girls in town Follow you all around Just like me, they long to be close to you Just like me,
I'm kissing him now Mwa, mwa mwa snake Mwa, mwa Mwa, mwa my little snake Mwa, mwa, mwa You're so cute Mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa Mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa Mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa, mwa I'm getting...
...Cloooose to you I'm giving him big old grandma kisses
This one's dedicated to your snake.
This guy is clean because he stays on my desk.
And then I have the little snake that goes on my journeys with me in my bag.
And then I have four more in my cabinet, in my display cabinet.
I'm kissing him like I kiss my cat.
Yeah, I have six of them.
I have six.
I want more.
Oh my god, someone sent me a post... a picture.
They posted a picture on Twitter earlier.
And they said they went to the cafe.
And then they said that they went to a store and saw a whole box of snakes, like figures and stuff.
And they had the little, the little power pro snake.
And oh my gosh, guess how much it was they were trying to sell it for.
Guess, guess how many, how much they were trying to sell it for.
Guess how much.
Okay, I'll tell you.
For 50 bucks, 4,000, almost 4,000 yen.
It was like almost 5,000 yen.
That's insane.
That's actually insane.
Every time I bought one of these, it's been like at most 1,000 yen.
Like so much money.
So yeah, what a scam.
What a scam to increase the resale.
No, I'm not reselling them though.
It's like 25, 30 dollars.
That's still a crazy amount.
Still a crazy amount.
So much.
There was something else.
Oh, and also, I went to At Home with Dusko.
And I got a maid.
And I chose her because at At Home, they show like what kind of things they're interested in.
And she had some similar stuff.
And I was like, oh, I want to talk to her.
And so, she came over.
And she saw my little snake on the table.
And she was like, snake?
And I was like, you know who this is?
And she knew him from Smash Brothers.
But she was like, wow, I've never...
She was like, I've never met a girl who did Oshikatsu from Metal Gear.
It's me!
I'm the Oshikatsu Metal Gear!
Yeah!
It's me!
You guys, I have to pee so bad.
Hold on.
Listen to...
Here, I'll put on a song for you.
Hold on.
I'll put on a song for you and I will be back before the song is over.
I have to pee so bad.
I've been holding it in for like the past half hour.
Okay, good.
It's over now.
Sorry, I also got some more food.
Take all your bags.
Sorry.
You are messed up and you hate me?
What do you mean?
What are you talking about?
You guys don't want to hear it?
Why do I hate you?
Chiragdor Okay, I'll sing something nice.
I'll sing something nice.
What should I...
What's something nice?
What's something that you guys actually want to hear?
I'll do...
I have three more songs.
Don't do that!
Do you want me to actually lose my jaw?
Wichita Line, man!
Oh my gosh, I love that one.
Okay, hold on.
I'm seeing a couple that I think I can do.
I'll do Wichita.
That's crazy, you're requesting that song.
I thought nobody ever knew that song.
Wichita Line, man.
I'm not doing break stuff.
No, sorry.
Didn't I try before?
Sorry, I'm wheezing while driving home.
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Actually, I want to see if they have any of these.
Let me see, hold on.
I might do something...
I might do something a little unconventional.
If they have any.
They don't.
You guys got lucky.
Wait, what else was it?
I saw other things.
It's been forever since you sang it.
Sang what?
Space Oddity?
We're just going full Metal Gear, huh?
Well, you guys are always...
Ikenai Borderline.
Okay, I can do that one.
That's two.
Can't stop the loneliness.
We're Touchy on the Floor by Bruno Mars.
No, I don't know it.
I don't listen to a lot of Bruno Mars.
No, wait.
Is that the...
That's not that one, right?
Appachoo, appachoo.
That's APT.
I would love everything when I look at you.
I don't.
What?
Wait, is that a song?
Achiagari by WUG?
Hold on, let's see.
Wake Up Girls.
Karaoke, Wake Up Girls.
I could probably do...
I'm trying to see if they have another WUG song.
I don't...
Have I ever tried singing Tachiagare?
I'm not sure.
Okay.
I'll do this, this.
Monkey.
I think this one, I think I have to put up two.
Wait, hold on!
Hold on!
Wait, hold on, not yet, not yet.
Gosh, I think two.
Hold on, let me hear what it sounds like real quick.
I'm a lineman for the county.
I don't remember how much I need to put it up.
Hold on, sorry, I'm adjusting.
For the county.
Okay, we can do this one.
Holding the line, holding the line.
I have to concentrate.
Sorry guys, hold on.
Maybe I could just do original.
Let's see.
Sorry, I know you guys can't hear.
For the county.
I'll do plus two, I'll do plus two.
And I drive the main road.
Or maybe plus one.
I love this song so much!
I'm glad that you guys like this song because I love this song.
I feel like a grandpa for loving this song.
Okay.
I am a lineman for the county.
And I drive the main road.
Searching in the sun for another overload.
I hear you singing in the wire.
I can hear you through the wine.
And the Wichita lineman Is still on the line
I know I need a small vacation But it don't look like rain And if it snows That stretch down south Won't ever stand the strain And I need you more than want you.
And I want you for all time.
And the witcher's all on man.
He's still on the line.
Back in cheese break.
And I
need you more than want you.
And I want you for all time.
And the witcher's all on man.
Sorry, back in cheese.
He's still on the line.
The back in cheese is on the line.
There was a back in cheese in my throat.
My car broke down you guys.
The day before I left.
So I can't get food.
I just...
I sound like I have Fogo's Vintage filter on.
I had...basically my car has been having issues.
My mint mobile.
I became Spongebob for like a second.
It's so true.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
I've been having issues with my car where it will sometimes be like...
I didn't mean to be rude when I looked at you as the name of the song.
Felipe, I'm going to give you some advice if you request songs in the future.
Always include who the artist is.
Otherwise, I have no idea what the song is.
So always include who the artist is.
I don't know the song.
I really don't.
I'm sorry.
This is serious.
I've been having issues where it will go...
I was so shocked.
I can't believe that it hasn't...
The check engine light hasn't come on yet.
I got a thing.
It's something to do with the transmission.
I got a little code reader or whatever.
I ordered one.
And it says it has something to do with the transmission.
So I was on the highway.
I was on the highway and...
I was going.
I'm just driving and it's doing this...
And suddenly...
There's the check engine light and then I...
And then the check engine light came on and then also...
It stopped accelerating.
So I was literally flooring it and it wasn't going fast.
And I was like...
I had to pull over.
Luckily, I was not on the highway and then I called a tow truck.
Yeah.
Now I have to...
I pulled over and it completely died.
It wouldn't move anymore.
So...
Yeah.
This here is out for me, I think.
If I weren't already dead, I think I would be dead.
So...
Yeah.
Yeah, I've been going through it lately.
And so I have to now buy a new car.
Yeah.
Sucks.
That's stressing me out.
I think that's also why I got stress hives.
Mobile phone.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Yeah.
So I have to get a car.
I'm going to look for stuff after stream.
Okay, I have two more songs I'm going to sing.
I already decided what they are.
So I'm going to sing those.
I wonder actually if... Let's see.
Hmm,
hmm, hmm.
Oh!
Ohayo, ohayo, ohayo, ohayo.
Pam, pam, pam, pam, pam, pam.
Ja, ha, ikudou.
Haiga, haiba.
Ja, ja, vaibou.
Waipa!
Yume wo miru nante kitto dekinai to Chiisana jibun wo mamori tsuzuketa Hidoku kizutsuite zankoku na umi ni Hana wo miresu guse wo muketa But you know, I am me.
I won't listen to any kind of deception.
I have no choice but to keep going without giving up.
I've made up my mind.
Wake up!
Bathe in the dazzling sunlight.
Now, the hope in my heart is overlapping with yours.
Stand up!
Because there is no night that never dawns, I believe in the smile of tomorrow.
I want to shine, my only one.
Now, let's go!
Come on!
Give me your heart!
I cried all the time.
I screamed all the time.
I kept searching for the lost love.
In the moment I stood at the edge of despair, I heard the gentle sound of the wind.
And then we met.
This is my stage.
Once again, I aim for that sky.
I flap my wings.
Wake up!
You woke me up.
I don't want to cry anymore.
Because you are here.
Stand up!
There is a future ahead of us.
So now, let's go.
Keep looking at me, my only one.
I want to convey my feelings more and more.
No matter how much I get hurt, there is something I can't give up.
Listen, listen.
I'll sing desperately.
You can laugh at me.
I won't lose.
One, two!
Stand up!
Wake up!
The dazzling sun is rising.
Now, the hope in my heart is overlapping with yours.
Stand up!
I believe in tomorrow's smile.
Wake up!
I'll deliver this prayer.
Now, I'm heading to my dream.
Stretch out your hands.
Stand up!
Let's run without hesitation.
In order to live in this world, I want to be with you, my only one.
Thank you for the car fun!
Thank you very much, everybody.
Last song.
Wow, it's already been three hours.
I will be streaming every day the rest of the week.
I'll have my schedule out.
Tonight.
Tonight!
Sorry, today's stream has been so entirely scuffed.
I apologize.
But it's been fine, so...
Oh, setlist update!
Oh shoot.
Are we saying Wichita?
Wichita Lineman.
And then...
Stand up!
And now...
Wait, did I sing something in between?
Oh, close to you!
Thank you.
I was like, wait a second.
17.
Close to you.
And then 20.
I was gonna say, I thought I was doing a total of 20.
Okay.
You guys always request this song.
You guys always request this song, even though I sang it 50 times.
And I've probably sang it 50 more times since I sang it the original 50 times.
Yay.
Okay.
Here I go.
Nice.
Wow.
Sorry.
Rest in glitch face.
I see it too.
Thank you so much for the Akadono!
Thanks for another Minton Karaoke and good luck with the new wheels!
Thank you Xenobowl!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys next time I see you!
Otsuminto!
Thank you for karaoke!
Sorry I'm so jet lagged.
Yeah, but it was also fun!
Thank you guys!
Otsuminto!
Bye bye!
How about bye bye?
I'm wishing you a bye bye!